president's executive order was greeted
with praise and skepticism Ivanka Trump
thanked her father for taking in her
words critical action ending family
separation at our border civil rights
legend Congressman John Lewis said the
order merely replaces the unacceptable
evil of family separation with the
unacceptable evil of child attention
Mireya Villarreal went to El Paso to
talk to people who live along the border
Matea good morning
well good morning we've spoken with
dozens of people here and virtually
everyone is excited and supports the
executive order signed by the president
El Paso is one of the safest cities in
America and with more than 25 percent of
immigrants living here it is also has
the highest rates of immigrants in the
country while many people in El Paso
were relieved by President Trump's new
executive order they also questioned why
separating children from families was
necessary in the first place I'm happy
he did it because I was sad this he
children taken away we didn't worry
about the immigration problem until he
made it never was they're not sending
their finest that I can tell you last
night President Trump repeated his tough
rhetoric regarding Mexican immigrants
that began in the earliest days of his
campaign they're bringing drugs they're
bringing crime they're rapists El Paso
resident Yolanda Torres and her husband
Willie used to travel across the border
to what as Mexico often before it got
too dangerous at one time it was so bad
out there
you know lots of shoe use letters
whatever so we try to avoid Mexico they
disagree with the separation of children
and say they feel safe in El Paso but
they also understand the President must
make difficult decisions whatever he
says that's the way it is really you
respect the president I do respect the
president okay you know you know I've
spoken with a lot of people that
actually work directly with immigrants
here in this city of El Paso they still
have a lot of questions right now the
hope though and the prediction is at the
tent city that is currently in Tornillo
that that could possibly be used for
detention of families to keep them
together instead of separating them
because right now that tent city is
being used for unaccompanied minors john
maria thanks